On fait le point avec Tamarsixs
de guerre, quel est l'état
des lieux sur le tx sur le tx s.
On va avoir une ca
- On se  avancées, ça
doit valoir la peine.
Mais si on regardeon regardeon s
troupes russes occupent en ce
moment 20 à 22 % du territoire
ukrainien. Mais ça comprend la
Crimée, qui était déjà sous
contrôle russe, des parties
importantes du Donbass, qui
était déjà sous occupation russe
prorusses. Donc, dans les faits,
à occuper... a réussi à avancer
sur 13 % seulement du territoire
ukrainien. Si on compare à
l'objectif... c'est presque
rien.
- Si les Russes n'avancent pas
l'Ukraine, Washington est
derrière l'Ukraine, la quet-ce
que cet appui de l'Ouest va
durer?
- L'appui, oui. Il ne faut pas
laquelle les membres de l'OTAN
se sont rangés et ont fourni de
l'aide à l'Ukraine. C'est
remarquable comme réaction. La
solidari
qu'on a les moyens de fournir
s des Zelensky? C'est
une autre question. Aujourd'huis
troupes et on acceptera rien en
termes de paix de la Crimée. On
n'importe quel coût.
L'aide internationale est de
l'Ukraine à se défendre, à
n'est certainement pas assez
pour reprendre et gagner la
promet.
- Il n'est pas dans une logique
de concession. La Russie non
plus. Mais si Washtait
toute lail
va falloir qu'il laisse une
partie de la Crimée et du
Donbass, Est-ce qu Est-ce qu Ese
c'est la voie de sortie?
- Poutine peut demain dire :
mobilisation générale, et
combat. Mais en termes deutionsu
cours des prochains mois soit
donc une intensité dans lescomùa
table et on va discutersérieusen
diplomatique d'une solution à
long terme pour la paix.
Et si on pose Zelensky à
accepter des compromis, c'es
pas les moyens de l'aider à
atteindre ses obje
populations... Par,,,,,,,,,
qui n'offre pas auais on
ne pourr
- Il y a une immobilité en ce
moment.
dans le temps? Est-ce que Biden
reculer?
- Vous connaissait bien laest é.
J'étais en Russie au mois dejuie
bureau, et les gens ne parlent
peur. Mais avec l'assassinat le
week-end dernier de cette
comment Patrice très pro guerre
et pro Poutine dans un attentat
à la voiture piégée, on peu
poser une question. Est-ce q
n'y a pas des groupes
travail de façon t
C'est une hypothè
pourra jamais écarter, qui
problèmes à Vladimir Poutine.
Mais pour l'instant, on n'a pas
de preuves tangibles pour